my name is Miles Morales I'm the one and
only spider-man at least that's what I
thought people have been wanting to see
Miles Morales on screen for the last
seven years what is it like to be the
one who's betraying him for the first
time on screen I feel blessed I feel
like I was chosen like you will be my
you know what if the fan interactions
been like so far has anybody come up to
you and been like man it means so much
to see this character on screen uh yeah
a few people I was on the street in LA
in Venice I was going to one of my
favorite restaurants on Havok any skater
dude Rose a little Spider Man I turn
around he's like dude sick man excited
for the movie either's goes on by the
business I'm like this is one instance
I'm driving my managers car in LA he has
a Porsche 911 and I was somewhere around
Fairfax and I'm rolling on the window
I'm honestly just looking at the window
something else and two guys really taken
home when you were cast in this movie
were you aware of how sexy and beautiful
this footage was going to be like did
you know exactly how the cinema you
talking about the film I mean all right
this man well I heard the names
that was all I needed to hear to know
that the animation and the movie would
be amazing for Sony's completely behind
it so yeah we know that Miles Morales
I'm Peter Parker
we know these characters we know we're
gonna love them there are so many other
characters being introduced who do you
think it's gonna be besides YouTube the
scene stealer of the film I'm really
into spider-ham right now I think
spider-ham is the one it can get weird
do you think there's a possibility of us
setting up setting up multiple
spider-verse films yes yes yes
[Music]